me
none
[音楽]
私の夢ちょっと唐突ですがお話しさせていただきます
私が住んでいる地域のみんなが笑顔で暮らせるように
まあもちろん子どもも大人もお年寄りも障がいのある人もそしてマイノリティと言わ
れる人たちも一緒に笑顔で暮らせたらいいなぁと思ってます
そんな究極のコミュニティをつくるために
今一生懸命階段を登ってますがそのお話はまた後で
ここからはそれまでの今の道のりを皆さんにお話しさせてください
まずはあの四年前になります
うちの路上曲で地域コミュニティサロンを運営することになりました
その時にみんなで地域が子どものためになることを何かしたいよねって話になって子供
食堂が出ました
私自分の子育ての経験や後テレビで見た子ども食堂のことがすごく印象に残っていたの
でもう迷いはなく
すぐ
友人に相談しました
その友人にいろいろ紹介してもらったんですけれども
まあその頃まだ札幌市内で子供食堂って本当に数えるほどしかなかったんですよ
ちなみに今は札幌市内に子供食堂ってどのぐらいあるか皆さんご存知です
グーとか200ではないんですけど50以上はあります
ただ残念なことにあのあっという間になくなってしまう子供職労もあるんですよ
まあそんな状況のなかでいろいろ勉強させてもらって開け市こども食堂を開設しました
私その時に一つだけ決めたんですそれはいたってシンプルで続けることです
せっかく子どもたちがこの場所追って選んでくれたその
コミュニティーを絶対なくしてはならない
それだけが私が決めたことでした
最初は10人くらいだったと思うんですよ
でそれからどんどん人数が増えて今は毎回40食用意しています
なくなります
で蓋を開けてみるとあの子供だけじゃなくて
まあもちろんすごく混乱を抱えている子どももくるんです
だけどあの経済的に豊かで
だけど親が全く子供お仕事が忙しくてみられない
すごい寂しい思いをしている子そういう子も来ました
あとは地域のお年寄り以外と楽しみにしてくれてみんなで私たちも言ってもいいって
言って
町郡上チームなんですけどやってきます
それ以外にもあの保育園に子どもを迎えに来たままがちょっと子育てから離れて食事を
楽しんだりといろんなことを
みんなそれぞれ楽しんでいました
よく貧困にスポットが当たりがちな子ども食堂なんですけれども
そんなことはなくてあのみんなで食事しているうちに何かちょっと違った形があるな
一歩進んだ関係を渡し気付き始めているっていうことに自分自身が気づきました
で子供食堂はあのもちろん食事をしますがそのために地域のね
八百屋さんがフルーツバイキングのこのフルーツ全部ね無償で提供してくれます
鮭が届くこともありますこれえりもから届きました
私さばきましたよ
何やだって話ですけど
でそういうのもあれば地域の人がこうやって小銭をいっぱいためて
で某番組じゃなくてここの子供食堂に寄付するがあって言って下さるまたねたくさんの
企業が協賛してくださったり食事を作ってくれるスタッフがいる
そういう人たちとみんな一緒に暮らせるコミュニティができたらいい
なってすごく思うようになったんです
でそうやって思うことでみんなのことが自分ごととして考えられるようになりました
これ自分をとって今日ね他のスピーカーある方も言ってましたがあの実はそう考え
られるようになると相手が必要としているものがわかってくるんです
でそれがお下がり
これが一つのその気づきの
あれだったんですけどあの私
ある子どもにおさがりをあげました
ところがその子の家は本当にも雑然としていてどこに何があるか分からない状態
そして洗濯機も壊れてました
親はもう全く子供に昔です
だから貰ってきたものが何なのかも分かっていない状況
そこで私その子と一緒にせっかく綺麗にしてねみんなくれるお下がりですから
畳んでしまって整えるということを子供といろいろやったんです
もちろん手洗いの仕方も教えました
そこで親に変化も現れて今は収納ケースをちゃんと買ってお洋服をきちっと畳んで
しまっていると言ってました
もう本当に誰が挙げればいいんじゃない相手の立場に立って何が必要かということを
考えるべきだなぁと思いました
そして仲良くなったシングルのままがある日
ねぇ
小学校の卒業式中学校の入学式立て続けでとても仕事を休めない
塚本さん入ってくれないって言われたんですよ a と思って
でその後に聞いたんですどうなんだろうと思って私でいいのっ
えっとめちゃくちゃうれしい
そうやって言ってくれて私入学式行ってきました
でそこで終わった後にその子がすごいキラキラした目で寄ってきて
どうもありがとうって言ってここにピターっとくっつくんですよ
で切っ
でもねいいのもねだからなんかこの感触が思い出されるんです
本当にだからなんかも私のほうがウルウルきちゃうくらい感動をもらっているんですよ
て私3の車で送っていくんですけど
アルコあの大学生子供速度に来るんですがその後本当に経済的な格差をもうしっかり
乗り越えて自分でちゃんと勉強して大学行った子なんです
深堀まなかちゃん
て彼女が車の中で私私毎年豊平区の成人式の司会をするんですね
それで車運転してますよ私サラマーゴちゃんの横でつかむさん今年もやりますか
嫌よ
て
あの私成人式なんです本当ってみんなに来てるんですか
や振袖
私振袖持ってないんですよね
私運転してだけど思わずけブレーキ踏みそうになりましたよ
だけど
何とかしようと思って
て政治意識の前にボランティアで着物を着せて写真を撮ってくれるという活動は多々
あるんです
でも当日となるとハードルが上がりますそれはなぜかというと
流出はどこももう着付けとヘアメイクの予約でいっぱい
要は本業でいっぱいだからです
でもそこもたくさんの方に協力してもらって
一緒に政治意識で写真を撮りました
ある意味この写真が今の私の活動の源になっているかもしれません
そして夏休みのある日
宿題があると言い出したございましたどんな宿題って言ったら家でカレーをつくって
そして
写真を撮って食べて感想を書いてもらう
いやー私は思いました今本当に家族のあり方が多様化している中でなんと昭和で
ハードルの高い宿題用途
うーんと思いました
そこでも決定です
何が決定か分かりますよね
カレーづくりプロジェクトですよ
でいつもやっている勉強会1時間早く来てもらってお世話になっている八百屋さんでか
いらし押してっ
で材料を切って
以下右手
できましたもうおいしいおいしいの大接したんですよ
もう総勢10人以上の子たちにもう美味しいと言われて
でもこの子はねてれるあまりになんて言ったと思います
すべてはかリールのおかげですって言ったんですよ
枯れる
まあまあでもそこから大爆笑の嵐だって
いやでもたぶんこの子のあの宿題の中のナンバーワンの思い出になったんじゃないかと
思います
やって自分ごとと思っていろんなことを必死で頑張ってきていると本当に手を出して
くれるか変わってくれる方がどんどんどんどん増えてきている
それを私あの今もすごく実感してるんですよ
子どもたちが勉強会をやりたい
でこうしどうしようかなと思ったんです
でそこでもこの振り袖で登場したまなかちゃんだ
講師をやってくれるって言う事でもうすぐ解決
で学習会をスタートしてそのうち彼女の友人の香りさんっていう人も加わってくれて今
順調に進んでます
私この4年余りで自分もすごく変化したなぁと思ったんですよ
もう人って違って当たり前で
てそれを認めることでイライラしなくなったり怒ったりあまりしなくなった
まぁどれだけ怒ってたの買ってみると思いますよね
でも本当に怒ったりとかっていうことがなくなったんです
そして自分ごととしてものをとらえるということができるようになってあの実はね
自分がこれは絶対いいよね
いやー良かれと思ってやってるボランティア
これが意外とそうでもないことにも気づきました
だから
私子供たちが求めていることや周りのみんなが求めていることを一緒に考えて一緒に
行ってあげていこうそれが一番良いて思いました
ある時ね凄く嬉しいことありました食堂に来ている
あ
シングルで貼っを子育てしているママや
ね子供を預けてお仕事しているママが食堂でお話をしてそして私であったことで今
頑張れてるしこの地域にずっと住みたいと思うって言ってくれたんですよ
いやーもうほんと幸せでした
あのね例えば今私が皆さんにここで話を聞いてもらっていることものすごく嬉しいです
よ
もう本当にみなさんありがとうもう感謝しますありがとうって言われたら何か心の中が
暖かくなりません
なんかこういう魔法の言葉っていいなぁと思うんですよ
でもね
皆さん実はその一歩は簡単なことかもしれないんです
今もし自分に自信がないとか何をやったらいいのか分からないと思っている方ここに
いらっしゃったら是非あなたが気になる人とまず会話をしてみてください
そして自分ができると思ったことを行動に移してみてください
私は結構あの車でみんなを送っていくときにいろいろな会話があって気づきがあって
そこからいろんなことをやっていきました
たぶん皆さんもどこかあの自分が過ごしやすい
そんな場所があると思うんですそこで第一歩始めてみたらいいと思うんですよなんかね
不安だったりするかも
しれませんが不安って裏返せばワクワクですから
ワクワクを一歩踏み出してみたらいいと思います
その一歩がもしかしたらお隣の誰かの支えになるかもしれない
えっそれがどんどん輪が広がってできることが広がっていく
あなたの一歩がそういう形をとると
世代を越えたコミュニティができていくんです
そんなコミュニティができたらいいなということを願って
開けす子供食堂は2019年6月に開しみんな食堂に名前を変えました
そうあの冒頭で私が言っていた究極のコミュニティ
それは
このスピーチ出てきたいろんな私と関わってくれる人たち
その人たちが少しずつ助け合って生活を共にする
生活を共にするシェアハウスが作れたらいいなと思っています
いや
作ります
そのためにこれから進んでいこうと思います
今年のテーマは
クロスオーバーですよね
この私の思いがこの会場にいる皆さんの心のどこかに少しでもつながってくれたらいい
なぁと思っています
これで私のスピーチは終わりです
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]